we were following breaking news of a
potential terror attack in France police
say that a suspect took people hostage
inside a supermarket in the south of the
country witnesses have told French media
the suspects shouted he was a member of
Isis at least one person may be dead
there at this time the suspect is still
holding a police officer hostage the
others have been freed this is happening
in TREB in southern France Elizabeth
Palmer's in London following these
breaking developments Elizabeth good
morning good morning police are still
trying to figure out exactly what's
going on inside the supermarket but to
go back to the beginning of this
incident early this morning four
policemen were just out jogging suddenly
a man drove up next to them and fired
several shots one of which hit one of
the officers in the shoulder he then
sped off in his car ended up in this
little town of TREB and ran into a
supermarket he is reported to have said
I am a soldier of the Islamic state as
they arrived shooting there were
shoppers inside they either fled as soon
as they could or they were released it's
not exactly clear whether he managed to
take them hostage for a while or not at
any rate they all got out there are
reports from French media that ten of
them were injured one way or another and
as you mentioned the gunman is still
inside the supermarket with a police
officer perhaps a hostage or a
negotiator and there are two bodies on
the floor visible through the windows
motionless the mayor of the town of TREB
believes that they are dead Yona and CBS
News will continue to monitor this story
Elizabeth Palmer in London thank you